all these years later you have not
stopped if you go to your imdb page you
have a ton of credits
you're still under 30. almost that's
really commendable i
was like one of my goals was to make a
movie before i was 30. i did it it's
done
but so many people love the idea of
something it's glamorous yeah i want to
be
this or that i want to walk the red
carpet i want to have the notoriety but
they don't stay with it because it's a
grind
so i never i was never motivated by
those things though like
walking the red carpet and the glam
glamorous
uh stuff you talk about i never really i
never
knew much about that stuff i didn't care
about that i was i wanted to just make
movies
it's hard to explain to someone um
that passion or that need you just want
to do it you just keep
and you want to do it bad enough that
you'll kind of like just about do
anything you know you
and you'll associate with people that
are feeling the same way that's what i
try to do
i kept my friends circle passionate as
well like the people that i would
surround myself with
as friends i would try to keep them the
ones that were also
pushing as hard as they could to get to
the next level of things and
constantly making themselves better
constantly challenge
one challenging one another and
you know shooting for the moon and maybe
falling short sometimes but at least
getting
you know a little further each time and
uh
you know it's been tough sometimes
because i
you have to leave some people kind of
behind i guess not
behind but like you just sort of fear
off in different paths
um that's been probably the most
challenging thing that's that's been one
of the things that sort of did kind of
get me to consider maybe quitting at
some point because it was
it was challenging my friendship
sometimes and you know that's tough
for a guy that comes from ohio it's like
one of the most important things to use
friends and family but
i don't know i've always believed in
myself enough that i felt that i was
doing the right
doing the right thing and it seems to
have worked so far all the choices
of course i've made some mistakes a long
way but my my main sort of
uh uh philosophy i guess would be the
word
of keeping you know surrounding yourself
with people that are like that
it just really helps out a lot you know
those are my best friends that right now
some of my best friends are you know
guys that are still trying to get to the
next level as well
and it's inspiring to see that from them
and then
hopefully what what i'm doing is also
inspiring to them
trade off you know but it's also yeah i
think your things that you can relate to
with people you can talk about
difficulties that are naturally going to
show up from things like
that you're doing um and you have people
that can relate to it
at that point did you feel pressure
to your parents to show that you could
make a living from this because they're
both professionals and they also
believed in you yeah you know i mean
it's a daunting task to come out of
a place where this kind of thing is not
really done that often
and to show up to la all of a sudden i
have to figure out
where you're gonna stand how you're
gonna stay afloat
i was i had a smart mother who made me
save up enough money to
to be able to basically live out here
for a year without working
i just i was able to get work pretty
quickly so i had enough
saved what you know that even if i was
living a little outside of my means just
from being in la in general i
could still survive for a longer period
of time i think that's a huge
very very important thing to for people
who are first starting out to do
and that is to save up a bunch of money
before you try to come out here because
otherwise you end up
chasing your rent every day and it will
be
very hard to commit to things that are
going to help you get better
even free things because when you first
start off that was how i got all my jobs
i would go on craigslist
and i would just take gigs that were
either no pay or very very little page
so i can get to know people and meet
people because all those type of people
are like you at that time and then if
you meet people that are like you
and you're all kind of coming up
together you help each other right
it's not easy to just jump on board
steven spielberg's next project you
can't do that you have to have
friends that will ultimately become
steven spielberg or
friends that are going to grow along
with you so that way you guys together
can
you have a little team with you you know
what i mean so that was part of my
strategy when i first moved out here was
to
at the time it was craigslist i'm not
sure how how effective that is today but
i know there's other things like
staffmeup.com and places like that
you can try to get work and put yourself
out there and you know
i would say if you're first starting out
for me the best thing was to take free
gigs
have a little money save the size so i
could do that but then you have
you those people that know you a favor
too so if they get a job that's paying
they're going to be more likely to hook
you up
also i had a reel which helped a lot
like i said before i've been making
movies since i was eight so i had a
reasonably
decent reel for my age you know i was 21
when i first moved out here so
i had a decent amount of stuff on my
reel for that that time period
and it was i think it was impressive to
an older group of people who were maybe
in their late 20s early 30s that were
in the position to hire me for things so
they'd be like oh man that kid's doing
pretty cool stuff already
probably he'll be good someday i think
that's what their mentality was
and so they would hire me and give me a
chance when maybe they wouldn't know if
they didn't see my work
so that was a big important thing too i
i made a lot of my mistakes early on
and then whittled down the best of my
work into a real
which i showed to people you know two
three minutes long
because a lot of my early fan film stuff
that i did with my friends in
college but it was good enough that i
felt confident to show it to people and
i was actually able to get my first
cinematography gig that way
a film called everyday joe a little
short film starred
uh jason charles miller who consequently
years later introduced me to tyler maine
which is how i got the job for compound
the first job i got in la was from
wasn't from him but
i i worked with him on that project i
met him on that project it was a free
gig basically
and years later that's how i got
compound so that's what i mean like
those people are gonna
move up you know the same time you are
and then you have a
good group of friends that you can trade
work and war stories with you know